me it's all about making the other  person feel that you're coming from a  place of empathy and compassion not just  judgment  because what that does is it enables  that person to have the opening in that  moment to feel the love and actually  then deploy vulnerability and humility  and maybe make that switch if they feel  the pushback right away like you're  [ __ ] right then they're gonna go on  negative to negative by being overly  warm up front and coming from a place of  blood by candor right you give an  opportunity for it to go one of two ways  if you come from a place of over  emotional frustration like hey kid  you're [ __ ] up you don't even know  who the [ __ ] do you think you and all  that well it's already over